hello everyone so yes tall the title of
the talk is collecting visualized
metrics with in flux DB and Gravano and
I thought I'll put that on because it
kind of looks like charts of performance
and I like cats so so a few words about
me I currently work at G research as
technology operations analyst I have
been using Python for about five six
years after discovering it when working
on an a natural language processing
project for a university and this is PI
data I like data especially the
visualization aspect of it as I first
I'll present on this subject so let's
start with tail so let's say that you
develop an application as most of us do
and you test it to iron out all the bugs
you optimize it you want to squeeze out
all the juice you can out of your
hardware you set up infrastructure the
servers whatever you need to get it
going and working and you release it and
life is great
everything works everything's nice and
tested because you of course have tests
and then what happens is some time
passes and some things begin to change
so new features get added to your
application either by yourself or
someone else on your team maybe there
are software upgrades and this can be
either your OS upgrade a kernel upgrade
maybe some driver upgrade that happens
and you don't even know about it because
there's someone else maybe a nice sis
I've been doing it for you there's
hardware changes CPU upgrades ROM
what-have-you infrastructure changes so
maybe your friendly networking team
changes the way requests are routed in
your internal network maybe that affects
you
again maybe there is more developers
without the code so you kind of lose
control of it and you don't necessarily
know what's going on there can be more
users and that can affect the
performance of the app for example and
what happens next is there's a lot of
questions that begin beginning to pop up
in your day to day probably so sometimes
you might be asked what is the
application doing right now and doing is
not necessarily clear here um another
question may be are we bought those
great servers we've deployed your app
and is it the good use of the hardware
maybe you can put something else on
there maybe maybe just the opposite
maybe we are bottling bottlenecking on
RAM or CPU or something else
I mean you profiled your application
before deploying it you expect your
hardware everything is beautiful but
then after some time it may not be so
anymore you may be seeing some
performance regressions maybe someone
comes and ask you well we've been seeing
a lot of problems lately jobs are taking
long maybe we need a cueing system
random things can come up and another
aspect is you could have developed
multiple features in the meantime you
don't really know whether they're used
or not are unless you actually monitor
and check that so some things that you
could try and do if you do not have
monitoring and metrics gathering in
place is you can do this but you
shouldn't you can do that more logging
because of course you have perfect
logging maybe you even have a system
that aggregates logs you can grab them
or search them you can try and dump the
application state when you're
investigating some bug's to a file and
try to dig in there you can try to write
to the database then you can control
through your version control system and
trying to identify who did what when
that might have caused something to
happen
and generally you scratch your heads and
you think really hard and it takes a lot
of time and whenever a new question
comes up you go through the sacrifice
again probably wasting a lot of time and
maybe not getting the answers that
you're looking for
so this gentleman here is known for
saying there must be a better way this
is not to mean that he endorses his
stock because he has no idea who I am or
that I'm giving it but I really like the
saying so let's think what we would like
to have in place so that we can avoid
the situation that I described so it
would be ideal if we had a way of
gathering machine level or operating
system level metrics some application
metrics we need someplace to put and a
nice easy way to explore the data that
we're gathering
preferably without having to employ a
DBA to do this for us or an admin or
someone else so this would be our wish
list not sure what's going on there
maybe it's a connection so let's start
with the things that we want to gather
and we would like to know the metrics so
this is a definition from I believe
Google define column metric let's not
the first one that comes up it's like
the third or fourth one because it talks
a lot about metric system obviously so
the technical one is a system or
standard of measurement well I prefer to
define it basically as a property that
we measure this is a metric this is
something we are interested in that we
want to know more about at croa we want
to collect that throughout the time so
basically it's not a snapshot view like
a lock would be but something that we
gather and pull of a collection off so
this is a sample representation of a
measurement and it's has couple things
that comprise it first it has to have a
name a value
time stun because we're looking at time
race data and potentially some metadata
if if that's allowed by your system that
you're gathering starts into so yeah so
this is two big problems in computer
science that everyone knows when I was
putting it together I put three and I
ruined the joke so it's no wonder
they're basically they want it I'm
talking about here is the naming of
things so we we've seen this and CPU
underscore user seems like a feasible
name but we could do something else as
well
so let's say here we want to gather a
number of open connections to a server
so we could name our series develop
connections but should we maybe do it
then it DB and connections should go
into the type of the thing we were
measuring it could do open connection
size of connections open who knows which
one is better I know any preference
anyone ideas no okay we could use dots
we could do well just what I did and
have have the DBE connections type open
we could do this use underscores use DB
server my host type open so basically
all our meta data goes into the name of
the thing and basically it's not easy to
say which which of those is the best I
think there's something so you have to
consider basically do you name your
series hierarchically or use tags the
other thing is that the way you name
your series may be imposed on you by the
tools that you use for example if you
use graphite for collection of your
stats you're pretty much into the bottom
camp because that's all you can do maybe
if you use open TS d be together you're
metric
you'll also be in the same camp because
tags are expensive to store the other
thing is the way you name things may
have performance implications if you use
a lot of tags as I said in open th dB
that's basically the way they are
implemented means that you cannot use
too many of them I knew them the
variation is not encouraged and you
cannot you shouldn't have like very tags
on a on a metric on a measurement
because there's very not performant the
meaning should be clear I encourage you
to use units
none of those examples had units on them
anywhere
so when time comes you don't really know
is it is it ratio is it a value of some
sort if it's a value what scale is it
measured in there's also a move to have
standard tag names so for example you
know some people call their server host
some other people could call it server
it would be nice to have some
standardization across your organization
or at least across your stuff as you're
gathering so what I like is just to have
metadata outside of the metric name and
that my look has not that big of a thing
but if you run across one of those
horribly long names it becomes clear why
that's a good idea
basically you have better
discoverability so if you use a tool to
browse through your metrics and we try
to find out whether it was was it server
dot server name dot something dot
something else or was it the other way
around
maybe there's no clear hierarchy so you
have to remember that or rely on the
tool to also suggest those if it's even
available and yeah I mentioned
performance so in in fact CB
specifically actually the the graphite
approach is encouraged in version 0.8
point eight which is what I'm basing
this presentation on just a side note
0.9 came out obviously last week and I
would not recommend using it yet and
that's why I haven't updated any of this
because it's a very new fresh and not
really yet working or battle-tested I'd
say so
anyway there is this thing called
metrics 2.0 it's an basically it's a
website by a gentleman who put together
some conventions for naming your metrics
um it's a good read I wouldn't recommend
adopting everything here's some nice
ideas about out of scaling for example
so if you include the units in your
metrics your application could use that
and scale things accordingly
automatically or has some nice features
about building dashboards automatically
for you this is interesting so an
example of what is encouraged in this
spec or collection of ideas is so this
is what I was talking about this is the
horribly named metric I don't know what
it is something to do with DFAS some
node right you'll note that the version
encouraged by metrics 2.0 actually has
back slashes in the amount point so I
guess the survey there's no - DFS then
that's the amount point but you have to
kind of flip from from slashes two
dashes because that's slashes are no
supported in the naming conversion
there's a lot of issues here whereas the
other version actually has units tells
tells the either to do they're looking
at it or the system it will use it what
type it is it says it's a gauge so I
prefer that to be honest so yeah I
suggest you have a look at that if
you're interested in it at all
and now it's off to the other part which
is the time series databases so so we
know we know what we're storing roughly
or at least how to name it you know what
it is that we're doing we need a place
to put those metrics in and time series
database is something that's meant for
just this use case so this again is a
nice definition from Wikipedia and it
claims that a time series database is a
software system that is optimized for
hunting time series data and so on and
so forth and that pretty much sums it up
but the question you might ask if you're
not used to using those systems or maybe
it's the first time you see one is so
why don't I just use my relational
database create a table order it by time
and get on with it right so here in this
example we have same metric that I'm
using is an example let's say we want to
store values of this type so I could
define my schema like that I have a
series name value timestamp and columns
for server and type those are my tags
and I could call it a day except so
let's say we have 10 database servers so
there will be 10 different values every
second let's say or every 10 seconds
there's 50 other metrics that we may
want to store and CPU IO and ROM don't
really have a server and that type
potentially so it needs other tables
they can there can be multiple tags so
maybe this series has two what if I need
five or four and what if I need to store
this for a whole year so that I can
always retrospect and see what I've
gathered so far and they gives there
some trends that's a lot of data and
another dimension to this challenge
would be the schema changes so this is
the example of a kind of
that so this would be our our series now
needs to store an origin of the
connection as well in front of a site or
a country code and what do we do Dan so
again you can be smart you know how to
design databases you define another
table that has just tags kind of like a
key value store and you could use that
and but really it's just complexity and
overhead it's a waste of time in unless
your job is to be a DBA or to design
those schemas why are you doing this if
you don't have to so some more things to
add to our wish list you recall that so
we want it starts and we want it
somewhere to put them and the place we
put them we would like it to be
schema-less so that you don't have to
worry about that ever you can write
whatever collections of tags and values
and it should just work it should be
easy to set up and maintain so no
migrations hopefully it should be highly
performant scalable and have data
retention management because if your
data set grows if you're only interested
in last year of data maybe there's no
point in storing everything forever and
deleting from the database can be
expensive so it'll be nice if there was
something built in that can do it for us
without even having to worry about it ok
so enter in flux DB it is a time series
database
let's open source and it doesn't have
any external dependencies which I guess
goes to the point of having easy
deployments in installation supports
HTTP API has a sequel like query
language um scales horizontally just
take that with a grain of salt because
the branch that I'm talking about Oh
point eight point eight kind of does but
it's not being developed anymore and
point-9 has a cluster size fixed at
three so I wouldn't really call that
very scalable at the moment some other
things that we would like to have it has
it so some things I really like about it
is you have the flexibility with tagging
you don't have to put your tags and in
the metric description no limits on
columns so not only some tags like open
is DB you don't need any other piece of
infrastructure to run this software is
self-contained and it's really easy to
just use it without having to understand
everything about it also millisecond
time precision is nice if you're doing
stuff that requires that so I don't know
if you can read it from the back it's
basically to set it up on any Linux box
you can just grab a package this is an
Ubuntu example so you just have to get
or sudo the package the package and just
run it and there we go so this is all it
takes to run a single instance there's
some things you can configure so you can
configure ports you can configure how
many nodes in a cluster you you want to
have things like that so really standard
standard stuff
it supports UDP as well if you prefer to
write over UDP rather than TCP and it
supports the graphic protocol if you
have any legacy monitoring that you want
to put in there so the API are really
simple to create a database maybe I
should step back for a second so the
data model here is we have databases in
which we have series and to which we
write points and that's essentially it
so we have an endpoint /tv
to which we can we can post a name that
will create a database if we post to to
a series after that data that database
ID
you can just post points that will
create the series automatically there's
nothing else involved and to query just
issue a get request data URL encode the
query that you want to do and you get a
JSON response
it also supports Jason chunking if you
so if you retrieve a lot of points so
you don't you're not sending it's all in
one among this bucket um this is just on
a require e this basically does this
series so tell me what series i'm i have
and the last one is just deleting a
database which is again a request you
don't have to do the authentication the
URL I suppose basic supports basic off
as well it's just for convenience right
so am i doing for time if you go through
this quickly language pretty much like
sequel select from where group by limit
relief from where drop series there's
some examples here it looks exactly like
sequel it doesn't have the same feature
set so you can't really do selects from
selects and stuff like that it's not
really good at composing compose iquitos
and again one thing I wanted to point
out is this if you want to select a
specific point you need to use sequence
number so that is something that is
populated automatically whenever you
write and you also need millisecond
precision to to get the value oh yes
I think regex is yes you can select for
multiple series you can have reg X's on
the fields or tags that you select as
well the two moving data we're close
again reg X's grew by can be used to
group by time and yeah so aggregate
functions that are provided are DS so
this is pretty much the I guess the
boilerplate set
should expect derivative is interesting
and can be useful histogram and
percentile the rest of it is really
nothing nothing extraordinary but it
should be sufficient I think right so
I'm not going to do this this is a admin
interface sadly because this is in an
iframe
it doesn't really render nicely and it's
very very tiny so I'm not very usable I
can actually have it open in our table
if you want to have a look
basically this is this is it I can
explore data so you can go to matrix
Explorer data you can also some queries
so we have the following series in the
metrics database name CPU swap stuff
like this you can write points you'll
notice that the language doesn't
actually support any keywords for
writing that's dumped to through the API
only that's why they have a separate
form here yes oh that's just how I named
my database ah she'll be using it a bit
later yes the driver the Python driver
has some traditions with pandas I
supports data frames you kind of have to
make sure that you don't have any old
values you have to sign it as your input
before you try to push it in because it
doesn't work too well with with nulls or
missing values right so there's a whole
lot of other stuff that I'm not going to
touch home just just a note here you can
do joints in marriages from series
continues queries are interesting this
is your automated post processing
pipeline essentially so any data that
comes in can be redirected somewhere
else by some filters or adjusted in some
way basically you can do aggregates on
the fly so you can keep collecting your
aggregate series based off the inputs
you don't have to recalculate that if
you know you're always interested in
sometime
of an aggregate and fan-out queries are
very similar it's just you can split an
event stream or a time series into
separate time series for performance
reasons cool okay so how are we doing on
the checklist
it is schema-less I would say it's easy
to set up and maintain with a caveat
that 0.9 is not yet ready and 0.8 0.8 is
not no longer supported highly
performant I would say it is linearly
scalable again I touched on that thread
already and it does have data retention
management so it has some nice features
not everything is 100% as I said but
it's getting there outside right so we
have we store store metrics in time
series database we need a way to show
them and this is the interesting bit
that I actually like the most
so graph Anna is just a dashboarding
tool
I shouldn't say just it's actually the
best one that I've seen so far and I've
tried a few I'll just quickly go through
the features so it's also easy to set up
it has metric discoverability built-in
so it has query builders and they all
actually pull down the values distinct
values for attacks for example and just
show them to you basically pick from
dropdowns instead of having to know what
your metrics are called
or do wildcards an Oracle thing is
sharing you can really you can either
share you can export anything to a PNG
or you can export it to a link and it
will have a self-contained data set
within that page basically stores the
snapshot without access to the query so
no one can actually modify the query but
I can kind of play with the data zoom in
zoom out disable series so like most of
the interactivity is there but you can
kind of isolate your data from the users
and I say killer combo infox DB that's
actually one of the two back
from pens I guess to influx the other
one is in flugel and it hasn't been
updated since last year so I wouldn't
think it will ever come back really so I
think we can skip that it's the same as
with with influx is just a package that
you get and install and everything works
nicely hopefully so this is the example
of the rich Ridge graphing that I
mentioned this is actually available on
the graph on our website if you want to
play with that looks like this I believe
they do snap shorting and do something
smart about always showing you the time
series as if it was today so it's always
fresh it's not a snapshot from you know
a year ago some cool things you can do
there's hovers there's zooming the data
table is there you can also well can
change colors of anything you can zoom
in or just show this series you can
control click that I think or not option
click that do you can actually hide this
which doesn't seem to be working now
anyway there's a lot of data ports here
that you may want to have a look at if
you're interested in this and there's
some nice walkthroughs and you can
actually see the queries behind it too
and also see how this is actually done
this is this is based on graphite input
source so this will look slightly
different then in flexi be but if you
were to go to the influx one you can
take a look at how how this wildcards
the query for example there's an
asterisk here this is again named this
way because of performance reasons I
wouldn't do it this way unless I really
have to this is another example this is
actually running right now on my machine
just a simple static electrode I wrote
that just gets me to CPU and memory
usage
it's pretty much the same the same idea
I'm in terms of actual display it's not
just line charts there's bar charts as
well and there's a single value displace
as well so here I believe in 2.0 or 1.9
hmm yeah 1.9 included like a single
value if that's of an interest so you
can do something like that you can have
like you can have a line behind it and
it's pretty pretty configurable so
imagine query editor um there's no way
to actually embed it in the presentation
other than taking a screenshot that's
what I've done here but it's really good
um I don't know if there's anything else
I can say about it's much better than
the admin default it's better than
writing writing queries or JSON messages
on the terminal okay so almost there so
some Python practicalities nice
alliteration so we mentioned I mentioned
that we need symmetric sprawl from the
system and from our application as well
so I will tackle this system stuff first
so there's this nice tool called glasses
which is written in in Python
coincidentally it's uses PS util
underneath the hood and it basically
looks like that if you run it in
terminal so nothing nothing spectacular
but I don't know pretty nice I kind of
dislike the fact that's using 5% of my
CPU here but maybe this was just a spike
I hope the best thing about it is that
it has a native export - in fact CB so
all you have to do is put that little
snippet of config in glances config and
run it with a flag and you'll get this
ish
so again this is running on my machine
this looks much better than what I wrote
myself to collect CPU and memory usage
it's much more detailed on a Mac not
everything is available if you're
running this on a Linux box there's much
more that can be collected like
temperature starts and I know a lot more
basically for Mac they don't have that
many start of things implemented yes yes
you can
so this is just a mean I think if I
remember correctly yeah that's like one
five and fifteen minute mean but that's
not the CPU that's actually the load I
don't remember how it's exactly how its
defined exactly yeah yeah yeah yes yes
you can and actually if i refresh that
there's actually a CPU charts at the
bottom as well but I'm the one did I
write it before that's so this thing
goes per core well it's it's not a real
core use this hyper threaded so it gives
you for course even though there's only
two but yeah there's some things that
you can do there this is an example I
then it's probably not very readable
this is just a sample of using the
driver to collect the application
metrics and how you do it
basically you have to import in flux DB
dot in flux to be a weight because they
sub sub module to the weight compatible
package now with the online becoming the
main supported one hmm create Jason body
create a connect create a client it's
not actually connected yet and then you
whenever you run a query it actually
connects and execute whatever you want
and disconnects so that's really pretty
simple you can run queries there's some
there's some database management queries
as well there's some user management
course if you need to do this and so
this is referring back to what you asked
about the pandas data source
so basically I created a little example
here I connect to Google get a few years
or five years for four years worth of of
stock data from Google for Apple Twitter
and forward and just write that so the
way you write it is only you have to use
the words it data frame client instead
of infox DB client it just handles the
data frame bit of it and that's all you
have to do the way it looks like is this
so I have a few things here basically I
have high low and close so close as a
yellow line high low you can kind of do
this this shadow effect basically you
disable the line display you drop shadow
to the low value and close will be
somewhere in the middle hopefully the
other thing that's that's shown is the
volume and I tried using bar charts with
daily resolutions don't equate okay okay
so some other interactivity features
that you can see here is you can see the
crosshair the line actually going
through both charts so you can kind of
if you have very long despite you can
kind of compare and contrast between two
charts if they're one under the other
which is pretty useful but I think we
could do a little bit better than that
and I have already prepared a few
examples so this is a template a
template variable which actually is
populated from a query so I do select
distinct ticker from my collection of
course this wouldn't perform very well
if you're serious is very huge but you
can do you can do time horizon on it
maybe like show me all the tickers from
the last day and probably it will be
most of them and then you can update a
chart by just using it drop down like
this which which is nice um you can do
even better I think we could do
something different where you can you
can do comparison between between stock
these are close prices again this is
going back to the
and for interactive bits and
discoverability bit you can kind of
prepared it ahead of time you don't
really have to prepare everything ahead
of time because you can kind of have
those central variables that are
automatically broken out from your
series if it's named uniformly so it's
really annoying yeah I think it's I I
think it's merely seconds sorry I'm
getting a few I'll check right yeah
you'd have to hear yeah yeah so you
depending on the data that you're
storing you may lose some resolution
that's good thing to keep in mind also
if you're doing further aggregates on
the data that's already aggregated in
some way because maybe you doing
something that doesn't make sense if you
further upgrade upgrade it but that's
that's a good point um last one I have
here in the pandas series so this is
another feature that's really nice which
is I don't know if you see this there's
this little value here the slew of blue
text that says time shift minus 30 days
so this is functionality that's built
into Griffin now where you can time
shift the chart essentially so maybe on
the same page you don't want to have
everything within the same horizon so
here I have a horizon from August 12 to
observe routines but I can have
discharges actually shifted by a month
or I can have it well if it's a life
updating website you can see maybe last
day last month and something like this
last week last month for different stars
that you measuring and yeah so I feel
since we're getting to the end of it and
this may look like a bit of a cop-out I
still haven't really sad or discussed
much what we should collect
these are some ideas it really depends
on your application and what your
application is doing and how its
implemented the basic stuff is are we
doing you know are we using our
resources or as a hardware sitting idle
for example things like open connections
active connections another really nice
use case is events or I should say
annotations that's again supported in in
gravano
where basically for example if you
whenever you have a release you can have
a post release cook that posts to a
series that's hey I released and this is
my release tag or release version this
can define I can subscribe to it and
let's say on the cpu performance chart
you can see exactly as a vertical line
when a new release came in so this is
one one example where you can easily
nail down where for example a
performance regression snuck in um some
other ideas the version being wrong so
if you have a let's say you have a
computer arm of I don't know
few thousand cores and a few thousand
machines and you deploy your application
whatever it is to all of them
you probably rolled it out in stages or
someone does you may want to know how
far along are we with the rollout so if
every running version of your software
actually keeps pinging saying oh I'm
version 15 version 1509 version 16 you
can easily say how far along you are
or maybe something didn't go right if
your sis have main team tells you yes
we've rolled out everywhere we started
everything but suddenly no because
something went wrong maybe I don't know
a deployment issue or something like
that um yes so one other thing I guess
if your application is doing any kind of
cyclical computation you might be
interested in how long the cycle takes
is there a correlation between I don't
that payload or a number of users or
type of competition is doing new
features being used so this is if you
have an API and you allow I don't know a
new feature you might want to you might
want to know how many users actually use
that if you want to deprecated another
feature this
is also a good you could think to
monitor and again whenever that API
endpoint is hit you can just say yes
just logon event just logo metric I mean
logger data point and see whether
numbers trail off as soon or as quick as
you want to I'm and you can then make
decisions based on that maybe encourage
users to move on yes so again a bit of a
cop-out as I said in the end it really
is up to you um because you know your
application best this is very against
generic and general overview of how you
do this I'm there I hope that there's
something here that you can use and
implement in your plate today especially
since it's really really really easy to
do it doesn't take much time and the
value that that I've seen at least in
technology operations where I do with
releases and things like that is huge
but what I wanted to stress is it's not
just a machine metrics it's also your
application metrics that can help a lot
so kind of trying to bring in that's the
point of view into into dev world from
operations world ok thank you I hope you
enjoyed that if you have any questions
yes
no no no it's maybe done the name of it
is a bit misleading here basically what
I do is I fetch that I can easily write
the data in the data frame to in foxy be
so Griffin is not talking to to to a
panda's data frame in any way it's it's
all going off off in Fox yes yes so
that's that's future in in in foxy B
that's very useful this is the you can
define a retention policy essentially on
a series and you can also do that
continuous query so if you are
interested in you can be computing
aggregates of different resolution all
the time and then have different
retention policies on every one of those
series
so essentially you kind of as your as
your metrics come in as your stream
comes in you found it out in two
separate series based on how you are
grade them and each of these can can
have different different retention
policies so that's this kind of built in
it's one of the things that is really
good for yes yes so so kind of jumped
over that because I was rushing a bit
but there's a lot of a lot of tools and
there is a collecti connector or plugin
machine and give it anymore hours right
to be honest I haven't I haven't used it
with it so I I don't know how how good
it is and where it has this support and
as you said the life support is there
but I'd have to check anyone else yes no
maybe
okay thank you
I hope you enjoyed that and I'll post
these after the conference it gives a
lot of things are running on my machine
here so I have to scream shout them or
publish them somewhere so that your
interactive cool thank you